OK, we now have just one week and one day from
the election. Three different models to look at.
Every model says the same thing. And people
emailed me over the weekend saying, David,
you've got to comment on these models because is
there any case to be made for anything other than
Biden crushing Trump? So let's look at the models.
And yes, every single one of these says Joe Biden,
is doing really well. The first model is the
538 model, which currently says that Joe Biden
has an 87 percent chance to win. While Trump has a
12 percent chance to win with a one percent chance
that neither candidate gets to 270 electoral
votes. This means if you run 100 simulations
with the current polling inputs and you adjust
for margin for error, Biden would win in 87
simulations and Trump would win in 12th. If you
look at the electoral vote projections of 538,
Joe Biden, they believe, will end up with
three hundred and forty five electoral votes,
Trump with not even 200. That would be a very
solid win for Joe. And then lastly, looking at
popular vote predictions, 538 estimates that
Biden will win about 53 percent of the popular
vote with a roughly eight point margin. That
would be the largest popular vote victory in a
very long time. And then if you look at the model
from the economists, the economists estimate is
that Joe Biden has a 95 percent chance to win the
electoral vote in terms of the popular vote. The
Economist says Biden has a greater than 99 percent
chance of winning the popular vote and cites
some popular or rather electoral vote numbers
which give a possibility that Trump wins
but overwhelmingly skew to Joe Biden in terms
of the Electoral College. As far as their best
guess on electoral numbers, it's not a range here,
but a best guess. The Economist believes that it
will be Biden 352 and Trump 186, which also would
be a huge win for for Joe Biden. And then lastly,
the in terms of the electoral vote trends, The
Economist has seen Biden's expected electoral
votes rising for the last roughly two months
since the start of September. And then we've
got the Princeton model run run by Sam Wang.
The estimate is Biden three six, the electoral
votes with the Senate going to Democrats 52 to
48 and Democrats keeping control of the House.
So what's the counter to all this? Because
it all just looks so great, right? Record
early voting more Democrats than Republicans
in some states. It just looks great. Well,
the counterpoints are number one. None of this can
account for voter suppression, and that could be
a big factor. Period. Don't even need to say
more. That's just huge by itself. Number two,
the polling looking at people who have not yet
voted but are likely to vote is overwhelmingly
in favor of Trump in some of these battleground
states, suggesting that, yes, the. Early voting
may well favor Biden in some of these key states,
but the people who will vote on Election Day
may heavily favor Donald Trump. So what can
we do? All we can do is vote. You know it.
I know it. We've got eight days to go. Let
me know your voting plan. I'm on Twitter
at David Pakman. And we will have much more on
this coming up a little bit later in the show.